if you know Donuts you know the pink
donut box especially if you're familiar
with Southern California which has
hundreds of donut shops most with the
pink boxes but while you may recognize
the box you may not know it's central to
a story about chasing the American dream
[Music]
the pink box phenomenon all started with
a man named Ted Ted Noi came to
California as a Cambodian refugee in the
1970s he got into the donut business and
became the owner of dozens of shops had
sponsored other refugees taught them the
business and helped them open their own
shops since Ted used the pink boxes so
did everybody else Ted became known as
the donut king my name is maily Chow and
I am these donor princes of La the donut
princess is great uncle the one and only
donut king Ted Noi he taught me Lee's
parents the business in the 1980s and
they started this shop Meili took it
over a few years ago and Beyond mainly
Ted's legacy lives on through you
guessed it
those pink boxes when we came to LA my
parent owned a doughnut shop for 26
years
we used to paint dota boxes in the Asian
community red is a lucky color so
therefore using the pink box it's no
coincidence about it the pink box is
overwhelmingly the favorite of the
doughnut shop industry that's Len bell
he should know his company manufactures
about 12 to 15 million don't
every year Cheers well the pink boxes
are still an iconic part of the donut
landscape owners are putting a new spin
on things
mailee makes some of the same doughnuts
her parents used to make but like
everything times on her a change in when
I took the business over for my parents
they were using the generic pink boxes
that you see everywhere but our
doughnuts were not generic and I needed
to reflect that upon our new upgraded
boxes and what is your mom think about
that Meili my mom does not really
approve him for the new boxes they're a
little bit more expensive and it's not
really what she's used to but I think
it's a sign of new donut times YUM
sounds delicious
you
[Music]